رغم كل هذه الاوضاع السلبيه القادمه في
2023 و 2024 قد يكوناني اسوا حسب خبراء
الاقتصاد البدايه من اسعار الغذاء في
الدول الفقيره حياه الملايين مربوطه بصفاق
الحبوب بين روسيا واوكرانيا وعدم تجديد
الاتفاق سيرفع اسعار الغذاء الى مستوى غير
مسبوق اسعاره القمح اصلا ارتفعت من 200
دولار للطن الى 350 فيها عز ازمه كورونا
قبل ان تقفز مره اخرى الى اكثر من 450
دولار بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه اعملوا اخر
اسعار الطاقه ليس الدول الفقيره فقط وانما
اوروبا ايضا الشتاء المقبل 2014 قد يكون
اسوا كما ذكرنا تامين الغاز له لن يكون
سهلا مع استنفادي مخزون الغاز الطبيعي
بحلول الربع الثاني من العام الجاري اسعار
النفط مشكله اخرى امريكا استنفذ نصف
احتياطاتها عوده الطلب الصيني ستزيد الضغط
على اسعار الطاقه وهذه النظريه يؤيدها
البنك المركزي الاوروبي هذاني الامران
سيكولان دافعا جديدا للتضخم الذي تحدثنا
عنه الحكومات لا تزالوا تصروا على رفع
اسعار الفائده لكن في المقابل ومقابل هذه
الاخبار المحبطه هناك امل انهاء حرب
اوكرانيا لكن ابتعاد الطرفين عن المفاوضات
والاصرار على مواصله القتال لايحي يعني
بالتسعيدي اكثر من التهديئه لكن حتى لو
انهيت الحرب هناك ما سيؤثر ايضا التنافس
الاقتصادي بين الصين وامريكا عاد للواجهه
الحرب التكنولوجيه باتت اكثر وضوحا السباق
نحو التكنولوجيا اشباه الموصلات
والجيل الخامس